Lisa I'd like to ask HL to respond in
the same way about religion and the
possibility of secularization in Sri
Lanka it's that if you see things the
same way that Peter does the problem is
actually the many many parallels have
been better just mentioned for example
the from their dislike of foreigners and
foreign things and foreign cultural
items and and any for the for example me
working in a foreign university again
they consider I'm consider somehow
international and I by the way I I have
enough material for what my next book
literally on my on my lap because I get
so much hate mail from single a Buddhist
right wing as a new phenomenon by the
weather with the rise of the Internet
there are expatriates internet groups of
propagandists the Sun nationalists right
wing I mean it's very interesting how
modern technology can be also used very
effectively to revalidate confirm and
strengthen right-wing extremist beliefs
or left-wing whatever being extremist
beliefs and more they are mostly right
wing so you have you have these
communities and so for in any foreign
thing is is quite unacceptable to the
nationalist religion nationalist as you
put it ideology as to secularization I
see no immediate future for it of course
as I yes we discussed discussed in the
morning there are our civil society
groups and there are intellectuals even
among the different clergy's like
Buddhist clergy and Christian clergy and
there is a also named Islamic and Hindu
there there are some people and but
these are these people in fact i have
personally been trying to at a personal
level I cannot do any propagandizing and
i do not even believe that is going to
be successful but at a personal level of
networking i was wondering whether these
people could get together and try to
exert some influence on the government
because that is another very important
thing to in the insole in the sri lankan
problem i think it is very important
that the government accept the idea of a
political solution rather than war which
they are now waging and they they claim
there they are succeeding they are
winning but of course this war if
supposing what this winning mean I'm it
doesn't it doesn't still solve the
problem they still have to sit down and
talk and still have to come up with
convincing proposals for devolution and
so I think if sec secular groups it now
there is another fundamental question
which again to some extent i heard
resonances in your presentation is that
there is a general breakdown of the
social order in i remember the time in a
personal experience this time i was
growing up there was supposing you know
i grew up in the countryside then even
which is quite far removed from you know
city life and various you know kinds of
things paraphernalia associated with it
including bureaucratic administrative
mechanisms but even even under those
circumstances some fight some some some
fighting in within hours there'll be
some police would appear and somebody
would be arrested and produced before
which is a predictable procedure and you
know and then and and after that
judicial proceedings and they they aside
the conviction or the person is set free
whatever there is a predictable
procedure but today the you
I could be chatting in our you know
borunda us or our house and somebody
could shoot you and there will not be
any s and there nobody we know that is a
dangerous there are abductions daily
killings and disappearances daily and
there is a sphere phenomenon called the
white when people say they saw somebody
is missing suddenly they have seen a
white wannabe and then so this of course
the suggestion is that it is the
government that's doing it and it may be
not direct of course it is it's actually
the government may be working with the
with the underground you know it is so
anyway it is the what I am trying to get
at is it is a whole dif number of
question one is the general decline of
the what might be considered the
underlying you know anchor moral anchor
of those are no society lives hellz
daily without that anchor and you have
to have ultimately you can have lots of
different political and the opinions but
underneath we agree on certain thing for
example that human life is valuable that
is a fundamental thing you agree about
all of us are supposed to agree but if
some people do not agree then there is a
real serious problem I think that is a
case in Sri Lanka so I think all these
other problems are really expressions of
this fundamental malaise that so when we
are going to truly address Buddhist
violence we actually have to address the
underlying questions and you know and
and some that may be actually finding
ways of you know promoting secularism